hier soir m6 diffusait un nouvel épisode
de la saison 10 de tokyo sous mille
téléspectateurs de plus en une semaine
alors dans l'émission ils sont pas allés
avec des mots bien à eux et on n'a pas
compris en fait de quoi il s'agit c'est
regarder top chef qui marche pas mal sur
m6 vous êtes content stable c'est ce
câble en fait déjà signé pour la main
sur balles et deux vous avez des bonnes
nouvelles
du coup j'ai fait un artichaut tournée
cage à cuire comme une barigoule 1 pen
la finma panneaux
et cette forme de fleur je vais à poser
sur une petite tarte bourdaloue hockey
une fois que ça ça vous dit que ça
commençait à compotée j'ajoute de l'agar
agar et j'ajoute d'uzès de combawa tu
mets un peu de temps c'est le chat
lierre qui marchait mais avoue regarder
encore comme ça la vérité je n'ai jamais
regardé mais c'est bien fait oui sans
pathos n'ont pas cessé expulsé pour
l'heure leur va naturellement vous vous
faites la cuisine
oui oui je sais je sais cuisiner le
couscous dacor ac a pris à quelques mois
non ouais j'ai acheté j'ai essayé j'ai
regardé sur lorsqu'une de la boîte la
santé
le profil de la voiture est inverse du
riz ou des pâtes faut d'abord mettre lé
dakor g ou très long à lui mais ils ont
déjà fait ils ont tout ça alors
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que ça allait
il est sorti il est prêt à appuyer
merci en tout cas massage et une planche
et c'était la première fois de ma vie
personnelle et alors là c'est réussi
alors il m'a répondu un gros grain comme
ça ouais t'es succès des graines de
couscous
ces boulettes c'était deux prévenus les
boulettes
il a décrit la mémoire de rené des pâtes
et du riz j'ai acheté du couscous j'ai
essayé trois minutes c'était écrit il a
fait trois minutes après juste à grain
vite fait car vite
je me souviens plus il y avait un truc
différent peut-être qu'il fallait mettre
l'eau avant est manon j'ai mis les
graines dans l'eau et j'ai couvert
[Rires]
une très belle interview j'adore